عاصمهنا ستغرق قريبا لا احد يستطيع مجابهه
جبروت البحر وما باليد حيله سوى الهرب
نداء الى الملايين احزموا امتعتكم فان
راحلو
تحذيرات العلماء على مدار سنوات وسنوات لم
تجدي معهم نفعا وقودم وصناعاتكم ترفع
حراره كوكبنا
وتفاقم الاحتباس الحراري انكم تتسببون
بثوبان جبال من الجليد من حولكم
وستغرقون قريبا لكن هل من مجيب اليوم
المخاوف باتت حقيقيه العاصمه الاندونيسيه
جاكرتا للضحايا مياه البحر ستغرق عاصمتكم
سنرحل بعيدا عن الشواطئ حيث لا يصلنا مد
البحار المرعب خطه متكامله اقرتها الحكومه
في اندونيسيا لنقل العاصمه بتكلفه 35
مليار دولار المرحله الاولى ستكتمل بحلول
عام 2024
والمؤسسات الحكوميه والمكاتب الرئاسيه وكل
شيء يخص الدوله ستنتقل اولا صادقنا على
قانون نقل عاصمه الدوله بتاييد غالبيه
ساحقه ولم يعترض على القانون سوى 50 نائبا
من اصل 575 عضوا بالبرلمان القانون يقضي
بنقل العاصمه من جاكرتا في جزيره جاوا الى
اقليمنتان الشرقي في جزيره بورنيو التي
تعد ثالث اكبر جزيره في العالم وسيطلق على
العاصمه الجديده اسم نوسنتارا ليست جاكرتا
وحدها مهدده بالغرق فلندا المدينه العريقه
تقع في مقدمه المدن المهدده كذلك الامر
فيه هوستين
والاسكندريه في مصر المياه ستبتلع تلك
المدن ان لم يكن هناك تحرك عاجل كما يقول
الخبراء مدن وعواصم اخرى مهدده ايضا
بالزوال لكن ليس بسبب مد البحار فهي معرضه
لخطر الهبوط الارضي بسبب السحب المستمر
للمياه الجوفيه او الغاز وانضغاط الارض من
الوزن الهائل للمباني الموجوده فوقها
وسائل الاعلام تحدثت عن احتماليه هبوط
لمدينه نيويورك
ارض مدينه نيويورك باتت تتهاوى بمعدل
ميليمتر واحد الى ميليمترين كل عام وذلك
بسبب ثقل ما تحمله على ضارها هناك اجزاء
من الارض تبدو اكثرها شاشه من غيرها انه
خطر يهدد حياه اكثر من ثمانيه ملايين نسمه
يعيشون على ارض نيويورك
بايديهم تسبب البشر في ظاهره الاحتباس
الحراري واليوم مدن عظيمه وملايين البشر
مهددون بسبب تابعاتها اضافه الى خسائر
اقتصاديه بتريليونات الدولارات فالاحترار
الارض عواقب اخرى تتمثل بشح الحبوب
والغذاء وانتشار الفقر والمجاعات وغيرها
الكثير